après avoir craché en direction de
chrétien au pied d'église à Jérusalem
cinq personnes ont été arrêtées mercredi
par la police israélienne depuis
plusieurs jours la fête de SCOT bas sont
plein et des dizaines de milliers de
Juifs convergent vers Jérusalem
plusieurs vidéos tournées dans la viilla
de lorossa montrent des Juifs
ultraorthodoxes crachant devant la porte
d'une église ou au Pier de groupes de
pèlerins catholiques selon ses fidèles
ce type d'agression ne cesse de
s'intensifier quatre personnes ont été
interpellées au sein d'un cortège emmené
par le Rabin Nathan Rotman dont son
frère député du parti sioniste religieux
et partisan du suprémacisme juif le chef
de la police de Jérusalem Doron jman a
réaffirmé que ses services ne
toléreraient aucune expression de haine
contre personne qu'il soit juif
musulmans ou chrétiens dans la vieille
ville et partout dans Jérusalem ses ccha
ont indigné jusqu'au sommet de l'État le
Premier ministre benamin netaniaahou a
fermement condamné toute tentative
d'intimidation contre des croyants en
revanche nouvelle preuve des désaccord
entre la police israélienne et son
ministre Itamar benengvir il a affirmé
lors d'une émission radio que cracher
sur des chrétiens n'avait rien de
criminel d'après la loi israélienne le
crachat sur une personne peut être punie
de 2 ans de prison s'il est motivé par
des raisons religieuses la police de
Jérusalem elle a annoncé qu'une équipe
spécialisé allait être formé pour
interpeller les
[Musique]
cracheurs